if I were a captain I'd look like me but  maybe a bit taller I'd be bigger I'd  want to get me a big bad ship my ship  would be the best ship in the verse I'd  have the best engines for quick getaways  state-of-the-art cockpit large cargo bay  and a med station my ship would be  printed I'm talking shiny pretty posters  pants oh I would definitely touch down  and see all the sights I'd take my time  exploring every corner of the first good  thing I've got that man I would have  visit all the planets I was certain a  few fights not bad my crew would have my  back if I was a captain if I was a  captain if I was a captain I travel the  bus I'd keep my crew together I would do  whatever it takes  stay flying  me i name to misbehave but that's just  me talking